welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and the mandalorian season 2 finale
brought back into the star wars universe
the hero at the heart of the franchise
making millions of voices cry out wait
no i'm not talking about luke skywalker
i'm talking about r2d2
the astromech droid whom we observed in
yesterday's big question has literally
seen
everything in the star wars timeline
including we just learned the
mandalorian and the existence of grogu
but in that finale episode it was the
way
r2 reacted that piqued my interest
huh cute little too cute this isn't just
the old generation beloved non-speaking
puppeted sweetheart meeting the new
generation counterpart
now we saw that with r2 and bb-8 in the
force awakens here there is the subtlest
implication of a
history at least a sense of recognition
and familiarity now it could just be r2
jumping with joy at the sight of
something so adorable that reminds him
of their old friend master yoda but as i
speculated my finale breakdown
r2d2 now does enter the field of
possible candidates of
the mystery of who saved grogu from the
jedi temple in order 66.
so did r2d2 save goku from the jedi
temple in order 66 let's go back and
look at the evidence of the timeline
because i think it's possible
and for a continued special thanks to
star wars card trader by tops for
sponsoring this video click that link in
the description to download the app see
in chapter 13 of the mandalorian
asochitano explained briefly the
circumstances of grogu's exit from the
jedi temple during that purge
he was raised at the jedi temple on
coruscant many masters trained him over
the years
at the end of the clone wars when the
empire rose to power he was hidden
someone took him from the temple she
said someone took him from the temple
but didn't specify that someone was a
person or a droid
though when she said many masters
trained him ahsoka kind of narrows the
scope of options because prior to this
chat hasoka had no idea grogu existed
despite the fact that the two were
contemporaries at the jedi temple
suggesting that this child must have
been
hidden in knowledge of his existence
limited to masters on the jedi council
yoda obi-wan mace windu the others who
were deployed to distant worlds at the
time of the purge so an astromech droid
like r2d2
would not have known about grogu's
existence oh and by the way
neither most likely would have anakin
who was deliberately blocked from the
rank of master
might have been for the reason of grogu
the only way anakin could have seen
grogu is if he accidentally stumbled
upon grogu's hiding place during his
room by room massacre but
that did not happen obviously because
anakin would have killed that kid
or would have handed him over to
palpatine which would have bypassed the
empire's whole need to get that kid in
the air of the mandalorian
however it turns out there is a very
good chance r2 was present at the temple
during order 66.
if you go back and re-watch revenge of
the sith c3po accompanies padme
throughout the film while r2
accompanies anakin r2 was not in ship as
he rushed to join mace windu in the
arrest of the chancellor but
after anakin returns from the temple r2
is with anakin nr2 has this interesting
exchange with 3po
what did r2 just tell threepio
presumably whatever crazy [ __ ] he just
saw anakin do to all those kids because
we pick back up with the conversation as
anakin sets off for mustafar
well he is under a lot of stress
[Music]
take care my little friend so this makes
it almost
certain that r2 was at the temple at the
time of the massacre putting him
exactly where he needed to be if he was
that someone who took grogu from the
temple now most of you know that r2 does
have a storage compartment in his shell
a compartment that grogu even now could
probably fit in
but in my grogu 28 years ago would have
been even
smaller than he is now now yes anakin
likely would have sensed a midichlorian
rich presence stowed away in his
astromech's belly
feet away from him but i would also say
that he should
have sensed this kid's presence when he
was exterminating each and every jedi in
that temple
he would have sensed it if one with
blood that potent slipped away
hel sidious totally should have sensed
grogu's presence long before this
so using this discrepancy whatever
container tiny little grogu was then
kept in must have had some
shielding that blocked any force
sensitive being from
sensing his presence it's the only way
those jedi masters could have kept him
hidden for that long and we can assume
that grogu was contained inside
something obstructing the view of who
saved him because when ahsoka scanned
his memories
she has no idea who saved him so let's
assume for argument's sake that it's
possible for r2d2 to have been the one
who toaded grogu out under anakin's nose
how exactly would that have gone down
and thanks again to star wars card
trader by tops for sponsoring this video
star wars card trader is the fun mobile
app where you get collect
and trade cards and digital collectibles
from the star wars saga there are daily
free cards and crystals
as well as some fun missions that you
can complete you can trade collectibles
with fans around the world or
salvage cards in workbench to receive
rarer ones
or play lock on to put new collectibles
in your sights
every monday during this season of the
mandalorian star wars card traders
celebrated
mando mondays by dropping special cards
from the most recent episode and with
the season now
over relive the best moments from the
series in the app with new content
coming every monday
find me on the app at username
newrockstars2020 and send me some trade
proposals i'm sitting on two
tier three anakin's and papa needs him a
cop bam download the star wars card
trader by tops on google play or the app
store by clicking the link in the
description and i'll see you there
i believe that for it to be possible
that r2 saved grogru from the jedi
temple
that he could not have done it alone
think about it r2 going into the temple
with no knowledge of grogu's existence
would not
think to look for anything or what to
look for or where to look
a jedi who knew about grogu would have
to retrieve grogu's container from
wherever it was hidden and then transfer
it to that astromech droid
a death star playing style maybe
thinking it would be the one place
right under anakin's nose that he would
not think to check
now i think one of the other jedi
masters i brought up in last week's big
question
remains a good option for that mystery
deliverer yaddle if
she is still alive and that legend story
about her death is indeed non-canon as
many legends death stories have been
retconned mace windu
if he survived palpatine's attack and
limped back into the temple
undetected jocasta knew the librarian
probably interested with all kinds of
jedi secrets and definitely had enough
time to do something like that
but how would r2d2 have unloaded this
precious cargo with no one noticing
because as you remember r2 joined anakin
to mustafar
where anakin killed the separatist
leaders and then waited for padme to
arrive
obi-wan joined her obi-wan and anakin
dueled and after the fight
obi-wan took padme to a medical base
where they were all joined by yoda and
bale organa this is where padme gave
birth to luke and toulea and then
croaked they decided leia would be given
to bail organa and
obi-wan would take luke to his uncle
owen and amberoo
and when this decision was made the
droids went with bail organa where
this happened captain antilles yes
johannes i'm placing these droids in
your care treat them well
clean them up have the protocol droid's
mind wiped
what
oh no of course explaining why 3po never
spoke up when he met several of these
characters later in the original trilogy
we've talked about this a lot
but as many have asked over the years
why didn't bail organa wipe the memory
of the astromech droid as well
sure you could say protocol droids are
all about that human cyborg relations
so their personalities and their
memories are very important to their
function you don't want this chatty
kathy spilling rebellion secrets to
other people but you know using that
argument our two's memories should have
been white
too clearly it was just a joke by george
lucas to scriver 3po but he has
explained other times that r2 is kind of
the narrator of the series he needs to
remember everything
sure now the expanded universe novel
darkness one the joyner king suggested
that r2's memories of anakin and padme
were still inside him just severed and
when luke repaired the joy during a deep
clean
or two brought up hollows of anakin and
padme and padme and obi-wan's final
meeting before mustafar it was super sad
but that story is not
canon really the character reason for
organa seemed to be that he wanted the
astromech to retain
certain secrets and one of those secrets
could have been
the additional child hidden inside of
him when bale got his hands on him
if grogu was present for luke's birth
that might be
why in the mandalorian he senses a
connection with luke when
luke saves them on gideon's ship grogu
could have been raised in
secret on alderaan with the organas and
leia remember leia never met yoda on
screen
so we would have nothing to gauge what
her reaction would be to a member of
this species there's also the fact that
alderaan kept
coming back up so damn much throughout
season two of the mandalorian
i served during alderaan look if you
were born on mandalore you believe one
thing if you're born on alderaan you
believe something else
you're going to wish you never left
alderaan even down to the opening
imagery of the season
that graffiti outside gorquess's hangout
grogu stares directly at a bunch of
orabesh that
translates to the word alderaan and with
alderaan destroyed and the organ is dead
there is no evidence of anyone who might
have lived there
also grogu is weirdly obsessed with a
sphere that looks exactly like the
instrument of alderaan's destruction
admittedly we have to do some reaching
to connect all the dots i get it but
r2d2 as the vessel of grogu's
deliverance is very possible
but there remains more to this mystery
of which jedi put this baby moses in
that r2 basket
hush now my baby
be still love don't cry
support this channel by checking out our
merch options at newrockstarsmerch.com
we got a great grogu one that you might
like follow me at ea boss follow new
rockstars subscribe to new rockstars hit
that notification bell thank you for
watching
i have spoken
[Music]
you